for company founded 65 years ago the
average age of a de debts and staff
comes as a bit of a surprise just 30
years old and added South German
headquarters that workforce is made up
from 64 different nationalities it is a
young culture most people are in the
twenties and it's a person that lived
away from home or it's the first real
job Courtney's a good example 35
American a designer it's kind of funny
because when i moved to to Germany
especially I thought kind of like I was
going back to school like back in
University why because everybody was
friends there's always like some sort of
party everybody's so much more welcoming
it's true you can feel it in the
atmosphere departments are linked by
walkways allowing fast connections and
added esas sporty ethos is important in
everyday life well we have the main
office building here we have a stadium
where I do my training at lunchtime
training at lunchtime alright today
we're gonna won't work out you need a
kettlebell and a partner
our designer runs c xt Courtney's cross
training it's so popular it's got a
waiting list and that's not all on the
same lunch break we see athletics and
football this employee fancied having a
go at archery and all as founder and
dassler looks on what could be more
appropriate